hello freak [ __ ] do it and that's why
it's like I get furious about the people
that misrepresent himself a lot more
than like there's all these scandals in
Hollywood now and and you know that the
Spacey's and the Weinsteins of the world
are so much more dark and evil than like
you know there's that scanner with Andy
Dick and I like Andy Dick I'm like The
Dude's an obvious dick grabber and he
feels bad about it and he [ __ ] just
wants to get punched when they asked him
what he was is an initial what was his
initial comment it was something like
like kissing and licking is what he does
he's been doing something like that no
mal misbehaviors is middle name or oh
yeah misconduct misconduct they're
signing up for some yeah yeah that you
know they were upset be fired him from
an indie film because of sexual
misconduct by the way I hate to be
cynical cuz I don't want to say that
anybody wasn't victimized but if I was
running an indie film that was so
[ __ ] stupid I hired Andy Dick yeah I
might be the type of guy that would make
a statement about Andy being Andy right
it's like we're gonna put our foot down
e-enough enough and then hey if you want
to see this film it's gonna be appearing
at the Sunset Plaza well it's good move
it's at least gets people talking about
something that they would never have
talked about because Andy Dick hops into
the the river of speculation as to who's
a molester yeah but like for me he's so
much like he's just he's not a snake
yeah it's not like the snake in the
grass where you like oh that guy's
misrepresenting himself done Cosby
exactly it's it's a dude it's like ah I
grabbed a dick and got knocked out yeah
he's just like the gravitons Derek
whoops he tried to grab my dick I
knocked him down and then he apologized
and I was like you're all good man I
know that you're just freaked out it you
get excited about Wiens man and rita was
like oh thanks for not really [ __ ] up
anything I'm like he's he's vulnerable
it's about vulnerability dude it's like
some people are just these vulnerable
people and like I'm a giant like he's
not trying to it's not about power he
just blacks out and grabs wieners yeah
but he's also like in a different way
than you he's a perpetual button pusher
buts not necessarily like the worst
thing in the world to be that
button-pusher but that is what he is
yeah like he's not he saw his competent
with it as you he doesn't navigate the
waters yes not grabbing dicks and ease
but like you know there's hills and
valleys to like your interactions with
people and like this certain Hills we
like you go you just get way too crazy
with it yeah and you bring it down and
you try to figure out what's what's a
good middle ground and II just it's all
spikes it's all I got and that's what I
have a hard time judging people like the
the prep the person I've always been is
trying to not be judgmental it's a it's
the snakes that I'm like oh you're
you're telling everyone about global
warming and your private jet like you
can go [ __ ] yourself you know it's like
it's the same with like Andy I'm like
Andy has never acted like not a train
wreck dick grabber and you're like when
my friend died the dude wrote me a
[ __ ] sweet email like he's a sweet
man he just blacked out tries to grab
wieners get sober no more Weiner grabs
and so when I seemed getting pulled
through the muck I'm like you can't
associate him with these like power
[ __ ] up guys that are like you want a
part watch me whack off on a Bicas
[Applause]
[Music]